engagé pour le 78 c'est sous cette
bannière que la république en marge des
yvelines dans sa campagne le parti
présidentiel a fait le choix de ne
présenter que cinq binômes pour les
élections départementales
on a eu un travail de réflexion pour
être cohérent avec nos choix aux
élections municipales
on a fait d un certain nombre de deux
d'alliance qui nous a permis d'entrer
dans les conseils municipaux de
travailler avec différents maires du
territoire et pour nous il est
indispensable que le travail au niveau
départemental soit cohérent avec sa
démarche a engagé dès la création du
parti des nouveaux adhérents mais aussi
des élus comme des conseillers
municipaux ou encore des mères les
binômes sont hétéroclites
je pense qu'ensemble on va beaucoup plus
loin et on s'est regroupé nos trois
comités existants se sont regroupés pour
faire un seul comité et permettent
d'avoir une task force pour les
prochaines échéances électorales à
commencer par cette départementale et à
deux sujets qui me semble important
c'est la mission sociale du département
rendu encore plus important j'irai du
fait de la crise sanitaire
c'est l'exigence de d'amélioration
d'efficacité de ces des services publics
à tous les niveaux administratifs et je
pense que pour cela il faut changer de
méthode se présentent aussi qui a déjà
moudni bhl candidate aux dernières
législatives dans la 8e circonscription
des yvelines
grégory pape conseiller municipal de
guyancourt ou encore laurent de bastard
médecin urgentiste à versailles avec ses
dix candidats la république en marche
souhaiterait installer un débat au sein
du conseil départemental